Russia's airstrikes targeting Ukraine's
power grid have plunged countless People
Into Darkness almost half of Ukraine's
power grid and the entire Nationwide
power grid is Now offline the result of
Russian attacks now that means that
millions of people are without power
water and heating tonight and winter is
knocking at the door
should Russian tanks covered in the
Winter's first snow a reminder of when
Kiev was much closer to the front lines
but while the fighting may be further
away
the war is ever present as daily Russian
strikes have plunged hundreds of
thousands Into Darkness
unfortunately Russia continues to launch
missile strikes on Ukraine's civilian
critical infrastructure Waging War
against the civilian population and
depriving them of light water heat and
Communications during the winter almost
half our Energy System has been disabled
while authorities are scrambling to
repair the battered power grid as best
they can
residents are preparing for more
blackouts
I'm not counting on gas
we bought firewood in the spring when it
was already clear it would be tough in
Winter I'm going to live with my parents
and use a stove for heating
it makes life more difficult but I
bought flashlights and candles so
everything is fine we will survive this
winter
but with Russian missiles striking
across Ukraine for millions that winter
will be cold and dark
well I'm joined Now by Maria avdieva a
Ukrainian security analyst she joins me
tonight from Odessa Maria it's good to
see you again and since you and I are
able to talk now via Skype I assume you
have electricity big question though
with the weather the way it is do you
have heat tonight
oh actually the place where I'm staying
now now hotel is running on generator
for the last three days because it's the
third day when the power outages are
extremely high in Odessa and according
to the latest 70 percent of the
population of people and consumers in
Odessa don't have electricity for three
days in a row so the only way how you
can get internet connection and
electricity is if if you have the
generator and the uh apart from
electricity communication is a very
vital thing that is now missing for a
lot of people because the antennas they
power the greater the communication grid
is needs electricity as well and the
batteries die very fast in four or five
hours and after that there is no
possibility for people to make calls
Maria let me ask you this thing if so
many people there in Odessa are without
power how are they how are they coping
because I assume not everyone can have a
power generator if you do have a
generator that means you have to have
enough gasoline or diesel to run it so
what are people doing there to cope
absolutely for a lot of people this is a
total disaster there are like uh
districts where it's everything is dark
and the situation is very hard not only
for Odessa but but the nearby regions I
have been also to micolav and took her
son and people are struggling because
for many electricity is also the mean to
heat the apartments because they can
then use some heaters and without the
electricity this is not working and
moreover the uh water pumps need
electricity to run so no electricity for
many people means uh no no no hidden and
no water and the temperatures are
getting really low now especially during
the night hours when people are sleeping
and what you are describing is a
situation that many people will not be
able to withstand for a very long time
you've got winter coming you've got
people without power without heeding I'm
wondering Maria do you think that we are
at the beginning now of another people
Exodus will ukrainians once again have
to leave their homes just to survive and
and to find Heat
people were trying to prepare themselves
for over this winter because everyone in
Ukraine knew and the government was born
in people that this will be the most
difficult winter for Ukraine ever and uh
but it's very difficult to prepare
yourself for this kind of situation so
for now people are still hoping that the
government will be able to cope with the
situation and this will not become
critical because the officials were
preparing for this as well many
hospitals schools kindergartens have
generators so people who work and who
take care about the children they can
provide this but for how long will this
last depends on how will Ukraine be able
to protect itself from the uh the
possible rocket attacks that might come
from Russia
Maria avdiva joining us tonight from
Odessa Marie we appreciate you taking
time to talk with us helping us better
understand what people there are going
through thank you
thank you it was my pleasure